we got rockstar apologizing halo
features being pushed and forza being
praised so let's get into it
rockstar games has released a statement
in which it apologized for the ongoing
issues with the gta trilogy the
definitive edition and promise that
further updates are coming to improve
the experience for everyone rockstar
said it has quote ongoing plans to
address the technical issues with each
game and the developer is hopeful that
all three games will eventually quote
reach the level of quality that they
deserve to be in the coming days
rockstar will release a new title update
for each of the three games that
contains improvements for quote a number
of issues however the patch notes have
not been released yet rockstar also said
in a statement that it is saddened to
hear that people are lashing out and
harassing the studio's developers across
social media in the wake of the issues
it asks the community to quote please
maintain a respectful and civil
discourse around this release as we work
through these issues finally rockstar
said it will reinstate the original
versions of gta 3 vice city and san
andreas on the rockstar store in a
bundle shortly these games were
de-listed ahead of the definitive
editions released on both pc and console
but rockstar did not say if they will
return to console as well everyone who
purchases the definitive edition on pc
through june 30th 2022 will get the
classic gta games through the rockstar
games launcher for free and if you're
curious what we think needs to be fixed
about the gta trilogy then check out
this video right here plugs plugs plugs
moving right along to halo if you
somehow missed it microsoft surprise
released halo infinite's multiplayer
mode this week in the form of a beta and
one of the related announcements was
that season one will run for longer than
originally planned in a blog post
microsoft's joseph statton said it
extended the length of the inaugural
season to may 2022 in order to give
developers enough time to allow season
two's content to reach its quality
standards and to complete the work on
the content in a healthy and sustainable
way for the developers microsoft has
said that the campaign co-op is expected
to launch in season two and given that
season two start date is now coming
later than expected it seems campaign
co-op has been delayed too forge mode
was expected to launch after season 2 so
it too has seemingly shifted to a later
date statin said 343 will make
announcements in january about season
two as well as its plans for campaign
co-op and ford
and sticking with the xbox news
microsoft has announced that forza
horizon 5 enjoyed the biggest week in
the history of xbox reaching more than
10 million players in that time the
racing game hasn't necessarily sold 10
million copies however as it's available
on game pass across console and pc and
there's no word if forza horizon 5 is
profitable from a cost perspective still
it's a massive figure and
a sign of the power of game pass forza
horizon 5 got off to a very fast start
reaching a record setting 4.5 million
people right out the gate so this
success is not much of a surprise and
given the strong start for forza it'll
be interesting to see how microsoft's
next big game halo infinite performs
when it releases not only is the game
included with game pass but the
multiplayer element is completely free
to play so its potential audience is
massive
and it's friday so you know what to do
hit that comment section and let me know
what you're getting into this weekend
what you're playing maybe a little halo
maybe a little bit of the pokemans let
me know
[Music]